no one's ever reduced the debt that much
we cut the federal debt in half
hello I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is November 2nd 2022 and that
was a very short cold open for you
because uh well we've got a whole bunch
of Joe Biden Clips today because he is
in Florida right now and he gave perhaps
his worst public performance yet filled
with a Litany of Lies confusions
obfuscations and all sorts of nonsense
uh no he has not cut the deficit in half
the deficit is going up every second as
I say this sentence right now and I'm
getting to the end of the sentence that
I'm saying at this very moment the thing
is freaking out behind me I don't know
what's going on over there the debt is
going up what's happening to the
background are the Democrats there
damn Democrats the debt is constantly
going up we are a debtor Nation we don't
really have much money actually we're 31
trillion dollars in debt Joe Biden
thinks he half that no he did not have
it he has increased the debt he has
blown up inflation you guys know it he
just lies and lies the best most
generous version of it is that he just
doesn't know what he's saying uh the
less generous version would be that he's
intentionally doing it uh anyway the
theme of The Today Show really is that
the craziness it's it's packing in right
now right because we got six days before
this election and everything continues
to Trend really really well uh for
people who love freedom for people who
dig America uh but of course the lies
from the left and the corporate press
and a certain set of big Tech although
that might be changing a little bit with
uh with the Elon Twitter situation the
lies the propaganda it is going to
continue and we got a couple a couple
really really like caught red-handed
ones before we get to any of that though
so the big story of a couple last couple
days
um was that this man apparently a nudist
and maybe a BLM guy and a trans activist
although if you listen to the mainstream
media he's a right-wing Maniac anyway
somebody who apparently Had A Hammer and
was in their underwear they somehow
broke into Nancy Pelosi's house and got
into a fight with Paul Pelosi her
husband and Paul Pelosi your husband who
was arrested did for drunk driving what
about a month month and a half ago a bit
of a shady character the Pelosi's by the
way who are worth I think like hundreds
of millions of dollars and somehow Nancy
Pelosi trades her her trading level when
she's doing stocks like this woman she
just Nails it I don't know how she does
it I don't know if when they're
injecting her with the botox it goes to
the part of the brain that figures out
how to how to trade really well but
she's made an awful lot of money while
being in politics forever uh and the
eyebrows keep getting higher in that
whole thing anyway the guy breaks into
the house they get into a fight with
Paul Pelosi it's all very unclear for
some reason they can't find any video of
the whole thing uh here's a tweet from
ABC that is a little bit curious U.S
Capitol Police had cameras outside the
house Speaker the home of house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi but they were not monitored
at the time of the break-in according to
sources familiar with the matter now
this sort of reminds you of the Epstein
thing remember when Jeffrey Epstein died
in jail and somehow the the cameras
weren't working for those few minutes
nobody was checking the cameras for
those few minutes you know we have
cameras at my house
okay so if you guys think you can get
away with whatever you're doing when
we're outside of the studio we're
watching I just want you to know that uh
we have cameras I have like 20 cameras
all over the house outside the house
inside the house uh we have a monitor in
there that shows 20 cameras I don't sit
in there monitoring it all day but it
also is recorded and then every month I
think we purge it something like that so
just because no one was monitoring the
Pelosi cameras we can't find out what
happened this thing stinks like a rat
something is not right but I suspect we
will not get to the bottom of it because
we don't seem to get to the bottom of a
lot of things these days important
things remember when uh there was this
leak uh this Supreme Court uh leak when
uh Roe v Wade was going to be flipped
and somehow we found out about it about
two minutes earlier uh two minutes two
months earlier we never figured that out
we don't seem to figure out things but
weird things keep happening very bizarre
anyway we are going to debunk some lies
and uh and leave you feeling good today
the the end of the show is going to give
you some juice to go with for the rest
of the day real quick before we we get
to any of that let me talk to you about
real estate agents I trust you guys know
already the buying of selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be 10 times worse
if you're not working with the right
agent usually our homes are our biggest
investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they work with only full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied
the agents they work with have long
track records and are the best sellers
in their field even under these intense
economic conditions with high interest
rates and high inflation real estate
agents I trust has provided their
customers with agents who've overcome
these challenges they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
head on over to
realestateagentsitrust.com today provide
them with some basic info their team
will contact you to make an introduction
to an agent in your town a new move to a
red state it is as simple as that okay
so uh I mentioned at the top we're going
to talk about some of the propaganda and
confusion that the mainstream media runs
with and you know they're always calling
us agents of misinformation while
they're the ones that are spreading
disinformation and censoring us for
telling the truth and all that stuff but
as we roll into these final six days
before the election it seems like it's
getting weirder and weirder it's partly
because of the the Twitter Elon thing
it's just got everybody freaking out
because I think a lot of people who've
done a lot of bad things feel like
they're about to be exposed also
obviously this this red wave is a coming
and because of that there's a feeling
like the Democrats and the Machine is
about to lose power there's just like a
whole bunch of things happening at the
moment so over on uh CNBC is this guy
Jim Cramer we've we've done a couple of
videos of Jim Cramer over the years he's
the he's this money guy you know he gets
in front of it he was sort of famous for
he'd run right to the camera and start
screaming about stocks and he gets a lot
of things wrong I guess he gets a couple
of things right interesting TV
personality anyway he's on a panel on CB
CNBC yesterday uh basically saying that
we need more and better propaganda and
by we I mean he means the machine needs
more and better propaganda kind of like
the Chinese and they gotta deal with
what do you do if you told people the
way to beat this is no vaccine first and
now you have a vaccine so I think what
you need is a propaganda
outside of the state infrastructure
exactly to start moving political
opinions but I think when we take a
propaganda we think about other regimes
that we didn't really appreciate
you're like silent I am silent I'm just
thinking about those poor people stuck
at Disney Shanghai Disney for it's I
mean it's the worst places to be stuck
but still Chief it's a real small world
after all that is a really weird moment
on CNBC you have a host one of their
main hosts basically saying that our
regime needs more propagandists to
promulgate the lies related to covet and
of course once you start promulgating
one lie you'll promulgate an awful lot
of lies promulgate there's a word for
you uh the host that he's sitting with
are are completely stunned I mean he's
basically saying we should be more like
China and then also the way he kind of
[ __ ] his head and lower certain looks
so the bags under his eyes get bigger I
mean this is like Disney villain kind of
stuff and then you gotta love just like
you know when they do these shows on
television you gotta understand they
have so many people that work on all of
these shows these these shows often have
staffs of 20 50 100 people if not or you
know so there is a step like you got to
imagine a control room where people are
like do something do something he
actually just said we have to be more
like China on television that's a
problem so then they just throw to The
Graphic and everyone's kind of quiet
anyway the reason I'm showing you this
is because uh there was an article in
the Atlantic that went viral for all the
wrong reasons uh over the last couple
days now the Atlantic which used to be a
somewhat kind of center right
sane
place of Journalism let's call it it was
a it was a place of extended uh
interviews and thoughtful pieces uh it
really has gone off the deep end into a
lot of trash but there was a really
interesting article uh piece that came
out called let's declare pandemic
amnesty by an author named Emily Oster
and this thing was going viral over the
last couple days because it was getting
a tremendous amount of pushback from I
would say people like me who actually
did not lose their minds during covid
people like you who probably did not
lose their minds during covid and now
that it is coming out that the vaccines
don't work the booster shots don't work
The Masks didn't work the lockdowns
didn't work there's all sorts of issues
people having health issues post getting
the vaccine all of the issues related to
young children who are speaking later
and having problems socializing all of
the stuff that you guys know about well
now that it's all being exposed is
there's a certain set of people who have
who were demanding mandates demanding
lockdowns doing all the bad stuff right
pushing you in ways you didn't want to
be pushed infringing on your free speech
and right to assembly and all of the
things and right to work and and make a
living and make choices for yourself and
have bodily autonomy well now that they
are losing the narrative uh they want
amnesty and that's very bizarre because
do they deserve it that's really the
question so I got a little bit from the
from the article and then we'll dive in
more in April 2020 with nothing else to
do my family took an enormous number of
hikes we all wore cloth masks that I had
made myself we had a family hand signal
which the person in the front would use
if someone was approaching on the trail
and we needed to put on our masks once
when another child got too close to then
my to my then four-year-old son on a
bridge he yelled at her social
distancing these precautions were
totally misguided in April 2020 no one
got coronavirus from passing some one
else hiking outdoor transmission was
vanishingly rare our cloth masks made
out of old bandanas wouldn't have done
anything anyway but the thing is we
didn't know there is an emerging if not
Universal consensus that schools in the
U.S were closed for too long the health
risks of in-school spread were
relatively low whereas the cost to
students well-being and educational
progress were high the latest figures on
learning loss are alarming but in spring
and summer of 2020 we had only glimmers
of information reasonable people people
who cared about children and teachers
advocated on both sides of the reopening
debate
another example when the vaccines came
out we lacked definitive data on the
relative efficacies of the Johnson and
Johnson shot versus the MRNA options
from Pfizer and moderna the MRNA
vaccines have won out but at the time
many people in the public in public
health were either neutral or expressed
to Johnson and Johnson preference this
misstep wasn't nefarious it was the
result of uncertainty we have to put
these fights aside and declare a
pandemic amnesty we can leave out the
willful purveyors of actual
misinformation while forgiving the hard
calls that people had no choice to make
with imperfect knowledge many people
have neglected their health care over
the past several years notably routine
vaccine rates for children for measles
peretuses Etc are way down rather than
debating the role that messaging about
covid vaccines had in this decline we
need to put all our energy into bringing
these rates back up pediatricians and
public health officials will need to
work together on community outreach and
polit will need to consider School
mandates the standard is saying that
those who forget history are doomed to
repeat it but dwelling on the mistakes
of History can lead to a repetitive Doom
loop as well let's acknowledge that we
made complicated choices in the face of
deep uncertainty uncertainty and then
try to work together to build back and
move forward okay hold on a second now
you may never have heard of this Emily
Oster I suspect she will not have a very
long career in journalism and the the
article itself I mean it was going viral
because people were just unendingly
dumping on her I don't want to make this
about her so let's remove her from this
equation I'd never heard about her
before this probably won't hear about
her again after this but she's wrong on
on almost every front not everyone went
crazy I have said many many times
and you can go back to videos I was
saying it on Fox not just on this show
I'm saying it on Newsmax whatever show I
was on that first two weeks I grant
everyone a Long Leash we didn't know
what the hell was going on we all kind
of freaked out we were doing all sorts
of in retrospect stupid things not only
with masks and social distancing uh but
you'd come home and you'd wash your
freaking paper bag from the grocery
store the endless amount of nonsense but
but we all got Bamboozled the machine
Bamboozled all of us and and maybe there
are some select people out there who
never got Bamboozled even for a day and
if if they're out there I really admire
them I don't know many of them but after
about two weeks most no I can't say most
people after about two weeks a certain
set of people realized what was going on
here and that this was an assault on our
freedoms and suddenly our right to
assembly which is a constitutionally
guaranteed right was taken our right to
free speech well suddenly we were being
censored all over the place people were
being forced to inject themselves elves
with things and get those mandates
people were being fired from their jobs
you guys get all of the stuff so no
amnesty you the people who did all of
the crazy things I remember one day I
was in at the height of the uh the
pandemic when things started opening up
again but you had to still wear masks
inside I was at Costco one day
and I'm getting a brisket and because I
was having an illegal party remember
that illegal party I had oops that was
good that was I got a 16 pound brisket
it was pretty sweet anyway uh getting a
brisket and I when I would go in I would
usually try to walk in without my mask
if someone asked me to put my mask on
which always happened in a rather
unpleasant manner I would put it on but
then I would put it below my nose and
then if someone would ask me again I
would put it above my nose but that was
my way of trying to stay somewhat sane
in the madness anyway I'm there at
Costco surrounded by a lot of meat got
the brisket in front of me this woman
comes up to me and she goes you now you
know masks don't work if they're below
your nose
but she came right up to me to say and I
was like oh I did not know that thank
you so much for letting me know that I
had no idea that I really appreciate you
telling me that a year into this thing
the point of that is that these people
who did these crazy things and assaulted
people in stores the woman if she had
feared covid if you really feared covid
the virus that was gonna kill everybody
would you be walking up to the people
who are not protecting themselves and
thus you properly how many videos did we
all see of people in masks chasing
unmasked people at Hobby Lobby or at
stores to yell at them and Tackle them
like if you really feared the virus you
wouldn't be doing that so this had
nothing to do with fearing a virus it
Unleashed something about a certain type
of person who wants to control other
people and that this woman had they had
hand signals while they were out on
Hikes and her son and they're screaming
about social distancing I don't know
about amnesty look we can I'm average
people who did the best they could and
sometimes made some wrong decisions all
along the way of course of course but
does fauci deserve amnesty does Michelle
wilinski who now has 18 booster shots
and 87 other shots who has covet as we
speak does she deserve amnesty does
Biden who said if you get the vaccine
you will not get her transmit kovid
deserve amnesty I mean the list goes on
of the people who lied about everything
and it's not just that they lied about
everything they tried to destroy the
people
who ask questions about things let's not
forget what the mainstream media did
when Joe Rogan had Dr Robert Malone who
has more mRNA vaccine technology patents
than anyone they he had him on and then
what did the machine try to do for him
to Rogan just for talking to Malone and
no one's questioning Malone's
credentials the machine for a week tried
to tell you that Joe Rogan was racist
they released all of these videos of him
saying the n-word although he wasn't
saying it in a racist manner he was
usually making fun of people that say it
and then CNN and everywhere else is
running should Spotify D platform Joe
Rogan and it had nothing to do with him
being racist
that is what we have all slogged through
so I don't know that these people
deserve amnesty again the regular people
who made some mistakes and P and and I
have unbelievable
sympathy for people who were forced into
doing it because they didn't want to
lose their jobs and they had to figure
out a way to put you know food on the
table people who who the social
pressures uh and who then injected their
children with things that they didn't
know what they injected them with I mean
it just they did something truly
horrific and and perhaps these people
need a Maya culpa they you can't just
have amnesty like okay you did all of
these bad things to all of these people
and you forced all of these people to do
things against their will uh but now
that it turned out you weren't right or
we're just going to let it go no you
gotta you gotta take some ownership of
it right and that seems to be the thing
that no one is willing to do so no
amnesty yet uh anyway I start with all
of that why that got me worked up
um I start with all of that because it's
emblematic and I would say thematic of
what is going on with the Democrats they
they did so many bad things over the
last couple years defund the police
inject people with all of this stuff
mandates
um you know these the inflation
reduction act which didn't reduce
inflation all of the woke stuff chopping
children's genitals off all of this
stuff that the average person has just
had it uh so here's just a Wisconsin
voter CNN went out to Wisconsin to chat
with people about how they're feeling
about the Democrats and what's going on
with this midterm election also top of
mind for voters is the economy people's
savings are being eroded by by Rising
inflation rates and things and and we
just need to get back to the basics in
this country the the Democrats have gone
way too far left for the majority of the
country yeah they're saying it on CNN
the Democrats have gone way too far left
if only there had been a set of people
on the computer machine that had been
trying to tell the Democrats for years
you don't have to do this liberals
defend liberalism stop letting the
inmates run the Asylum take out the
squad and return to your roots that are
just an honest and as I said to Bill
Maher liberalism is something worth
saving in its truest form but the
Liberals failed liberalism or maybe
liberalism failed the liberals so that
is what we are going to continue talking
about in just a moment but you know with
this election coming The Blaze wants to
help you make sense of it election night
is of course just around the corner six
days from now and the stakes have never
been higher for the midterms several
races across the country have been very
interesting the past couple weeks will
Republicans be able to win the senate
seat in West in Washington state of all
places perhaps is Kathy hochel really in
trouble in New York yes will voters
punish Gretchen Whitmer for her covid
lockdown insanity and finally give her
the boot please Lord there's a lot to
cover in this election cycle and we've
got you covered Stu bergier who kind of
serves as Blaze media's resident
physiologist which is a fancy word for
someone who studies elections put
together a comprehensive guide to let
you know exactly what you need to look
out for on Election night head over to
theblaze.com election guide to receive a
free copy of Blaze media's Ultimate
Guide to the midterms delivered straight
to your inbox again that's Blaze the
blaze.com election guide and we'll send
you everything you need to know to be
ready for election night and now back to
me okay so as we roll into these last
six days since the policies aren't good
it's a little late for the Democrats to
be like you know what um we've decided
not to chop kids genitals off and
eight-month abortions do seem a little
excessive and we're going to lower taxes
no it's too late so what do you got to
do you got to keep rolling with the lies
and the propaganda and the fear it's all
they've got that is that is the kitchen
sink for them right I said yesterday the
kitchen sink in essence was throwing
Obama out there but it's the same thing
you just throw Obama out there to lie
about the same thing scare the hell
everybody scare the hell out of
everybody about the Republicans
um here is Gen sake on as you know she
is now an MSNBC contributor she went
from being the chief paid liar at the
White House and then she just took a job
in journalism just like journalism just
like that she now works for MSNBC and
here she is saying that the Democrats
there was nothing they could have done
about inflation just because they're in
charge of everything they couldn't have
done anything I mean what do you want
from these people speaking of that
environment Jen mean when you look at
the economy and you look at inflation it
consistently raises the top issue to
voters and Republicans when you ask
those folks who say that they're
consistently saying they're going to
vote Republican by pretty lopsided
margins is there anything Democrats
could have done was there a missed
opportunity here for Democrats to not
face that kind of a headwind look on
inflation it's a global issue it's
happening around the world I think
there's not a lot Democrats could have
done to change that reality
complete nonsense complete nonsense I'm
going to give you some stats in a moment
but just if you took econ 101 in college
maybe not even in college did you learn
anything about basic math or checks and
balances or the red and the black when
you were in high school perhaps How
about if when Joe Biden came in he said
you know we're going to cut taxes for
everybody so that the economy can get
going you know we've been going through
this coveted thing it's been a tough
thing we want businesses to feel like
they have a little more money in their
pocket so they can spend a little bit
more money so that they can hopefully
hire more that gets more people out and
about and shopping and doing things and
then the economy kind of chugs along
sort of like it did under that Donald
Trump guy that would have been one thing
but I don't want to just give you my
crazy theories on the economy how about
we give you actual numbers on what the
Democrats did to basically tank the
economy and cause inflation to go up and
uh contrary to what Joe Biden said not
half the debt I mean unbelievable that
he lied about that uh here's some info
from visual capitalist in 2021 the U US
government spent 6.8 trillion on various
expenditures and government-aided
programs so the government spent get it
again
6.8 trillion that's an awful lot of
money a lot of zeros there on government
programs so they took money from you
right from the taxpayer and then they
decided to do whatever they wanted to do
with it and often it is completely
nonsensical stuff or we you know we're
bombing somebody or whatever it might be
or it's handouts that then keep people
in poverty you get the rest of it so
let's get a little bit more here
statista gave us some info in 2021 the
total revenues of the U.S government
totaled around four uh for basically
four trillion US Dollars now the problem
is
and any of you who've ever balanced a
checkbook would understand this uh when
you're uh spending money what you want
to do is spend a little bit less than
you're bringing in you bring in a
certain amount and then you go okay I
have this amount and I shouldn't spend
more than that because then I'm not
going to have money and then I'm going
to be in debt and then I have to pay
interest on it like say to China so you
understand that the two there was an
increase of the debt of 2.8 trillion
dollars in 2021 under Joe Biden the
democrat congress they did not have to
spend all of that money and the things
that they spent the money on actually
damaged the economy the inflation
reduction act do any of you think that
by the government taking money out of
your pocket and then somehow giving it
back to you that that caused inflation
to go down well that's that was 2021
let's jump over to 2022. here's a quote
from the center on budget and policy
priorities in the fiscal year 2022 the
federal government is estimated to spend
5.8 trillion amounting to 23.5 percent
of the nation's gross domestic product
of that 5.8 trillion over 4.8 trillion
is estimated to be financed by federal
revenues so they just keep taking more
and more of your money do you get it so
we are adding more money to the debt we
have a lot of debt and one day China
might call us and say hey we'd like our
cash and the thing is we don't have it
so it actually
is a good thing that we have weapons
that really is where we're at I mean you
can really think about it just pick any
episode of The Sopranos any whatever
your favorite Mafia movie is someone
borrows money from somebody you ain't
got the money you don't got the money
and then what happens you get a bullet
in your head so we're we're entering
that territory because at some point all
of the people who have lent us all of
this money and and then who love
watching us spend like drunken Sailors
right they love watching us just do more
and more damage to our economy it
weakens us domestically and then what
position does it put us in well when the
when the mafia guy shows up at your door
uh for the money and he brings you know
he brings Vinnie and Tony and everybody
and these big guys and they're about to
beat the [ __ ] out of you it's like you
better have some weapons so I guess
that's what the United States has at the
moment uh but The Economic Consequences
under the Biden Administration have been
basically catastrophic we've got some
more info from the U.S inflation
calculator the annual inflation rate for
the United States is 8.2 in the 12
months which ended September 2022 after
Rising 8.3 percent previously according
to the U.S labor department data
published October 13th so look I'm not
going to sit here and say that there
isn't anything going on worldwide of
course there is right there this Ukraine
thing has caused all sorts of problems
and Russia and gas and what we've done
domestically here not to drill and all
of these things these have all caused
problems and other countries are dealing
with it but it's not the fault of other
countries right the Buck has to stop
with somebody and if remember for six
months when they kept saying it's
Putin's price hike and it's like all
right maybe I'll Grant you something
there we could we can go down that road
Putin controls a lot of energy he sends
a lot of energy to Europe
if their prices go up because he's
holding back on them or there's a war
whatever it might be uh that could
affect our prices here but if at the end
of the day if an authoritarian leader of
Russia can basically decide to tank our
economy because he's holding off energy
from Europe uh then you're not a very
good leader you should have thought of
how that wouldn't happen right they
didn't have to spend that much money
it's just as simple as that they could
have done something different uh here's
a series of Democrats lying in an effort
to defend build back better which we all
knew was not going to do any such thing
today 15 recipients of the Nobel prize
in economics released a letter in
support of the president's Bill back
better plan including four Nobel prize
prize winners recently highlighted in an
open letter 7 a 17 excuse me uh Nobel
laureates who have conveyed this will
help address inflation 13 13 excuse me
14 Nobel laureates and economics said
it'll actually bring down the cost so
we'll reduce the deficit and it was
totally paid for and it's going to
reduce inflation
17 oh Excuse me yes 17 Nobel laureates
in economics I think 15 Nobel laureates
in economics released the letter
yesterday
17 Nobel Prize winners in economics have
said spontaneously wrote together
guys
they can't figure out how many Nobel
laureates said what and when they said
it why they said it but they sure do
know that they said something it's so
ridiculous and who gives a flying F what
a Nobel Laureate says how about people
that are in charge of Industries and
economies how about small business
owners how about you looking at your
checkbook at the end of the month right
checkbook you guys don't have checkbooks
do you damn you kids I had a chat I
don't even have a chat book anymore but
I had a checkbook once it's a little
paper and you get a paper cut it was a
nasty thing but guys the point is they
they know they know that everything they
have done has damaged the economy and
now I present you with Don Lemon over at
CNN and as you know Don Lemon was
demoted he nobody was watching his uh
late night show so what happens in the
world of democrat privilege you don't
get fired for doing a crappy job
generally you don't stelter actually did
get fired that was the level of his
crapulence lemon just got demoted to the
morning they were like you're not very
good at this at night why don't we just
try it in the morning which is sort of
like remember Brian Williams NBC news
anchor after he got caught lying about
some stuff they're like you can't do
this on on NBC anymore we're going to
put you on MSNBC it's so bizarre anyway
uh lemon had John fetterman on John
Federman as you know he's the Democrat
lieutenant governor of Pennsylvania
running against Dr Oz he had a stroke
six months ago the guy is having trouble
speaking but putting aside the stroke
and not and not to mock any of his
language stuff or any of that his ideas
are all terrible they all are about
releasing more criminals he loves all of
the woke stuff all like he is like sort
of Ground Zero Democrat like if it's if
it's all bad it is encapsulated in this
guy and on top of the fact that he can't
speak here he is with Don Lemon talking
about inflation well let's talk about
inflation because that's a big concern
for voters what do you think the biggest
cause of inflation is and should the
Biden Administration be doing more
no I I just do I I think that that
simply is also we have this talk about
the trillions in in massive tax uh tax
uh cuts to the corporate uh tax
structure as well true
oh
you know maybe I was a little too harsh
maybe maybe he is making some sense and
I should come around to some of these
ideas uh here's a gratuitous for uh one
for you here's just some awful moments
from Don Lemon I'm not listen again I'm
not a political person I'm a person who
lives in reality I'm a journalist the
Republican party is obsolete we cannot
sit here and pretend like well you
Republicans it's a cut them a break
let's we want to hear what if they have
a lot to answer for right now our
democracy is endangering it's because of
one party and that's the Republican
party they are the party of everything
that they're trying to pretend that
they're not the people who are in
Charlottesville that's not us yes it is
you what are they essentially saying
that they don't trust people who don't
look like them we have to stop
demonizing people and realize the
biggest Terror threat in this country is
white men and we have to start doing
something about them there is no travel
ban on them there is no white guy band
so what do we do about that the only
party now
that is operating in reality is the
Democratic party just objectively
speaking I say oh my gosh
Nancy Pelosi is a boss people who Us New
Yorkers we've known who Donald Trump was
for a very long time think about the
Despicable people we've had in history
okay now I'm going to use an extreme
example
um think about Hitler anyone who is in
that white house and who is supporting
him is complicit in their racism is the
president declaring war on Americans
open your eyes America open your eyes we
are teetering on a dictatorship and
let's not forget if anyone is judging
this I'm not judging this our country
was started because this is how the
Boston Tea Party
rioting
can we just clip that do I even have to
add anything like what is the point I
mean the guy is just awful the funniest
part of that I mean we were all cracking
up throughout it was when he said uh
there is no white guy band and Conor
over here who happens to be the fairest
skinned of all of us you kind of freaked
because you know he'd come for you first
you know what I mean I've got a little
more color Phoenix a little a little
more olive skin but a white guy like you
if lemon had his way
band anyway so of course what are they
going to do so wait just a little more
on Lemon so do you see how horrible that
guy has been for so long like everything
he also like I'm not a journalist I just
live in like everything about him is
just completely ridiculous and awful and
then what did they do as I said earlier
they were like you can't have a show at
8 uh PM it's a bit much with this
nonsense uh let's put this guy at 7am or
whatever is it's just so insane uh
anyway what of course are they gonna do
over these next six days well they are
going to continue to lie on what's
happening in terms of crime that you
know is happening violence uh election
manipulation disinformation and all that
so we'll get to more of that in just a
second I want to talk to you about
kamikoto uh you know it's time to up
your kitchen knife game with kamikoto
knives I love these knives uh using
traditional techniques kamikoto crafts
beautiful knives using steel Source from
Japan each blade is made with techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife Smiths they come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box and
every blade is individually inspected
and comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel Edge
kamikoto knives can achieve a wickedly
sharp edge the kind you just can't get
with other knives these are cut through
your rib eye like butter sharp knives
kamikoto knives are used by several
chefs working with Michelin star
restaurants around the world they make a
gate amazing gifts
that come in beautiful gift boxes you
can maintain each knife's edge with one
of kamikoto's sharpening wet stones and
like I said they're so confident in
their product that each and every knife
comes with a lifetime guarantee if you
go ahead and buy Now kamikoto is
offering you an extra fifty dollars off
site white on top of their Black Friday
sale it's not even Black Friday but
they're throwing it a Black Friday sale
all right why not go to kamikoto.com
Reuben and use the offer code Reuben for
an extra 50 off that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash
reubencomicoto.com
Reuben and actually we made a tri-tip
last night and we used the uh it's not
quite the butcher's knife it's like half
the butcher's knife just perfect just
perfect anyway all right let's jump back
into it so what are they going to do
they're gonna lie about everything
whether it's Joe Biden lying about uh
the deficit and inflation and all of
that or it's just mainstream media in
general lying about what's going on with
crime and what's going on with the woke
stuff here here do we have the warning
there you go it's the ladies of the view
here's Joy Behar lying about crime I
want to say there is no both sides here
no and a lot of them like to say it
including Ted Cruz when he was here and
I'd like to remind everybody that it was
the Democrats the not the Democrats who
stormed the government that day and try
to kill the vice president yeah okay and
the Republicans now coming up to the
next election which is next week by the
way
um that all they do is talk about crime
crime crime well I looked it up murders
in major cities have fallen by four
percent so far in 2022 compared with the
same period a year ago so crime is not
on the rise it's actually going down
under
okay so we're going to give you some
stats um Joy is a liar you know she's a
liar
um the fact that she even mentions
January 6th it was the Republicans who
stormed the capital and tried to kill
Mike Pence I know a bunch of people with
no weapons who had no plans again there
was the guy with the Lego set and we
apologize for that
um it's just pure nonsense you know
what's happening in New York City and
joy you've lived in New York City all
your adult life I used to live two
blocks from you and when I lived there
in New York City I used to see you
wandering around every now and again I'm
guessing you don't wander around as much
I am completely confident in saying that
you are not wandering around New York
City as much as you used to because it
is not safe in New York City right go to
Midtown where it used to be bumbling and
and bubbling with people in suits going
to work doing things it just ain't
anymore it's a lot of people kind of
looking Shady wandering around and the
smell of weed everywhere it ain't safe
so anyway we're going to give you some
actual stats so uh she was almost sort
of right about one thing but there's a
little context that of course she left
out uh here's some info from axios
overall violent crimes spiked 4.2
percent from January 1st to June 30th
2022 compared to the same period last
year the survey by the major cities
Chiefs Association found robbery
skyrocketed by nearly 12 percent and
aggravated assaults increased by about 3
percent the survey of 70 agencies found
now here's the real interesting one from
Time Magazine homicides and other
violent crimes dropped slightly in the
first half of this year compared but
violence in major American city Still
Remains dramatically higher than it was
before the pandemic the new statistics
come from the Council on criminal
justice which released its mid-year 2022
crime report on Thursday examining crime
rates from 29 cities homicides decreased
by two percent between January and in
June 22 compared to the same period in
21 okay however the slight decrease is
less satisfying when considering that
homicides that's murder people
hit historic highs in some cities in
2020 and 2021 the homicide numbers for
the first half of 2022 which are based
on data from 23 cities are still 39
percent higher than they were in the
same period of 2019. so this is also one
of those ones where as I often say you
can't totally get lost in the numbers
there's a little bit of reality that you
just have to feel if you are let's say a
small business owner in New York City do
you feel confident that your windows are
not just going to be broken the next
time antifa or BLM wants to March
through and Destroy things say after a
midterm election when it doesn't go the
Democrats way and they decide to kind of
release the pressure again with a little
little violence little let's burn down
at Pep Boys on a Target right on top of
we know what's going every freaking day
you can see a video of what's happening
on the New York City Subways with people
being assaulted and attacked and and
pushed into Subways and a whole bunch
more but what are they going to do and
yes
yes without question I'm sorry Joy Behar
you're a liar without question this is
happening in democrat-run cities more
than republican-run cities as we covered
yesterday 24 of the 25 most violent
cities in America are Democrat mayor-run
cities the one exception is Jacksonville
uh okay so facts those are just facts uh
here's Jen saki uh talking about how all
of the stuff happening it's really
because of those mean Republicans who
joke around about stuff I don't think
Kerry Lake and Ted Cruz are going to
come to anybody's home and threaten them
their silence and their jokes are giving
people a green light out there a lot of
crazy people people who are following
conspiracy theories online it's almost
like whack-a-mole for law enforcement
and Ted Cruz is not coming to my house
thank God but he is allowing and giving
the green light for this to happen
ah so Ted Cruz and Carrie Lake are
allowing violence to happen now it's not
Ted Cruz or Carrie Lake supporters that
were rampaging through cities for two
years right no those were Democrat
supporters those were your people Jen
saki also I have never once heard Ted
Cruz say that political violence is okay
I've certainly never heard Carrie Lake
say that but do you not realize the
ultimate irony of what you're saying Jen
saki if you think that they are somehow
instigating violence either through
jokes or their silence well as you lie
about them right there are you not
instigating violence about them like
that's how this crazy Merry-Go-Round
game can go if you want to play it that
way but it's not just Jen saki of course
uh election denier Hillary Clinton was
on a joy read
I'm getting too old for this [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton on Joy Reed uh and uh
well January 6 blah blah so I want to
take this a step further away from the
incident that terrible incident with
Paul Pelosi and broaden it out because
what we have with the rhetoric coming
from uh the Republican uh candidates
from their party right now is so
disturbing I didn't see a big outpouring
on the part of elected officials to
stand with Nancy Pelosi the way she has
stood with Republicans as well as
Democrats in times of real terror like
on January the 6th
it's so disingenuous it's remarkable and
I just want to say as someone making fun
of Hillary Clinton right now I did not
kill myself I have no intentions of
killing myself I did not kill myself and
let's just keep the uh the cameras on
all the time
um
Nancy Pelosi when Steve scalise was shot
up by a Bernie supporter
um were the Democrats all running around
uh saying nice things no of course they
weren't we've shown you many compilation
videos Maxine Waters and the rest of
them get in their faces AOC the point of
protest is to make people uncomfortable
also if you keep calling people white
supremacists and Nazis do you think that
your base might do some crazy things
about people look nobody's hands are
totally clean here I'm not going to sit
here and tell you that every Republican
has done everything right of course not
uh but but the the the level of her
thorough dishonesty is just incredible
but that should not surprise us because
Hillary Clinton as you know is an
election denier Senator Ted Cruz who was
here on the show when we pressed him uh
on the Maga Republicans election denial
he did whip out some sort of prop and he
argued that your mother did the same
thing
um I do think that he knows uh that uh
he's an illegitimate president
I'm pretty sure that I remembered that
next day I was standing behind her when
she conceded yes he's an illegitimate
president and that she said while she
had campaigned very hard against
President Trump uh she hoped that he
would be a president for all Americans
illegitimate president you know I think
that Senator Cruz just might have a
slightly different memory of that
I do think that he knows uh that uh he's
an illegitimate president
yeah you guys got it you got it by the
way when Sonny Hosten who is just you
know my feelings about Sunny Hosten when
he whipped out Ted Cruz he whipped out
some sort of problem some sort of prop
it was a it was a piece of paper that he
had in his pocket that went through all
of the times that Democrats had denied
elections and Democrats had done things
violent but they were completely rude
and dismissive to him uh including the
fake conservative on the panel Alison
what's her name Allison Ferris something
like that anyway let's get this to the
free state of Florida because right now
as we speak the elderly man pretending
to be President Joe Biden is here now
Florida I'm very proud to say uh is
trending so red it's ridiculous when
Governor DeSantis came into office a
couple years back there was about a 30
000 deficit in terms of registered
Republicans to Democrats meaning there
were 30 000 more registered Democrats
last I heard it is now over 300
000 more registered Republicans than
Democrats here also Ron DeSantis who is
running for reelection and obviously is
going to win by a landslide and Charlie
Chris that he's you know he's basically
running against an empty suit I mean
really really just terrible dude
everything that everyone hates about
politics uh Char the guy that that
DeSantis ran against last time was
Andrew Gillum who turned out to be a
meth addict so you know he was caught
doing a meth orgy look nobody's perfect
okay nobody's perfect but that's how
close even Florida got to the precipice
of insanity because imagine had this
orgy meth addict Democrat been in charge
during covet maybe Florida wouldn't have
been as open maybe DeSantis wouldn't
have ever taken the national stage and
maybe other Governors and other states
wouldn't have been brave enough to stay
open and fight and maybe we wouldn't be
in what now is looking like this this
potential Red Wave situation right so a
lot of good things have happened here
anyway Joe Biden came here yesterday and
although it's not looking good for the
Democrats I don't even know why they
wasted his time so he came we showed you
that cold open he made up this nonsense
about inflation and the deficit here he
is debuting his fake southern accent and
of course not even given the line
properly
the senator from Florida
going after Medicare and Social Security
I tell you what I don't know where as
they say that something doesn't know
where you all been
hot damn boy
I tell you look
you know I've only been in Florida for
about 10 months I have not heard anyone
talking like that damn boy
I'm Foghorn Leghorn I said I said what
the guy is just not right in his head uh
here he is completely making up uh a bit
of information here because well you
know what I'm going to play it and then
we'll you let's just see if you can
figure out how he's making this up first
how many of you know somebody with
diabetes needs an insulin
well guess what
and we when we when when when Debbie and
I passed this law it included everybody
not just seniors
and so what happened was we said okay
you know how much it cost to make that
insulin drug for diabetes
cost it was invented by a man who did
not patent because he wanted it
available for everyone I spoke to him
okay
Joe you never spoke to him it was uh the
1920s when that happened you never spoke
to that guy so he just made that up and
then this one is really twisted he has
done this several times uh he starts
talking about uh his son and claims that
his son died in Iraq his son Beau Biden
not not the other son not the crack
smokings on his son Beau Biden did fight
in Iraq he died of brain cancer six
years after leaving Iraq but listen to
Joe Biden no change in the quality of it
just changing the price
and they talk about inflation
you know we're dealing with it for a
couple of SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing I mean
excuse me the war in in Ukraine
and uh think of Iraq because that's
where my son died
the uh because he died
yeah I mean his son did not die in Iraq
his son left Iraq in 2009 he died in
2015. he's made this this mistake or
whatever it is he's done this repeatedly
like this would be 25th amendment [ __ ]
if it was a republican but we just keep
letting it go we keep letting it go
anyway then he ends this Meandering
mumbling nonsensical speech
um well look what he did at the end of
this one so God bless you all God
protect our troops and God gives some of
our Republican friends some
Enlightenment thank you
God the anger the way he said it at the
end Enlightenment the anger and uh sorry
man you're the one who needs in life
well you need a lot more than
Enlightenment Joe Budden you need a lot
more than that but okay so let's uh
let's talk about what's going on here in
Florida because again I think this is
the blueprint for a future America it is
the blueprint that every state should be
modeling and you know what even
Democrats
in Florida are realizing how we good we
got it so this is the former Democrat
mayor of Miami Beach Philip Levine on
CNN saying yeah Floridians get it and
and they've had it with the Dems and
there's something good going on here
truth but I think it's too little too
late and President Biden coming here is
fantastic but unfortunately the
Democratic party of Florida has been in
a semi-conscious coma for a long period
now and I don't think a week out that's
going to do much if anything whatsoever
I mean think of what's going on as far
as the messaging Florida's been hitting
on all cylinders and I'm a Democrat
telling you this what a Floridian is
concerned about they're concerned about
inflation they don't pin that to the
current Administration in Florida they
pin that to Washington to the Democratic
party they're concerned about
immigration they're concerned about
crime think about what's going on in our
country right now people are getting
mugged they're getting mugged on the
city streets but they're also getting
mugged when they go to the grocery
stores so that is something that they're
pinning on the Democratic party in
Washington they're not pinning it on the
Republican party that's controlling the
State of Florida so I don't believe that
will have any impact if any at all at
this point and so late in the game
warmer Democrat Miami Beach mayor by the
way we have a Republican mayor in Miami
Beach right now mayor Francis Suarez who
I interviewed I've interviewed him a
couple times but one of them was about
two three weeks ago Miami now is the
fittest city in the United States it is
the healthiest city in the United States
I think it is the least crime for a big
city in the United States we are
bringing in all sorts of tech companies
businesses exploding they're doing
incredible amounts of construction we
have buildings going up everywhere the
roads are being redone it's like it's
all working here and why is it all
working here because the people
thirty thousand extra people voted for
Ron DeSantis instead of Andrew Gilliam
and these last couple years Ron DeSantis
grew into the role you know sometimes
sometimes people are born to lead
sometimes people kind of stumble into it
I don't know which is which with this
anthis but he clearly has become the guy
that we need at the moment uh he
released his campaign released this
video yesterday this is their final
campaign ad before the big election on
Tuesday
laughs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
aren't you glad to live in the Free
State of Florida
[Applause]
we are going to carry this torch of
Freedom onward because our mission is
very simple we are keeping the State of
Florida free thank you all God bless you
pretty solid man closing out in uh in
true style the same style that he has
governed with for these past couple
years uh Freedom that's it that is
what's bringing people here that is
what's flourishing here uh and that's
what I'll be voting for uh on Tuesday
you guys going to vote for DeSantis I
guess I haven't asked you oh good all
right that would have been weird that
would have what if suddenly you just
like but turned around your hat and it
just said Charlie Chris that would be
something uh all right a couple comments
from the locals community and then we
got a cold close for you Jeannie says ha
let's stop demonizing people and
recognize that white men aren't people
nice down yeah it's everything that they
do they talk out of both sides of their
mouth it's everything that Hillary does
she accuses half the country of being
deplorables and racist and everything
else and then says that it's Republicans
who are instigating and inciting
violence with their words I mean it's
the same thing sake does it's the same
thing that AOC does the rest of them but
again you guys can see it now and as the
censorship machine crumbles at least a
little bit at the moment because of the
Elon Twitter situation
we've got a chance to get more and more
people to see the world as it is not
necessarily as they wish it would be
Chuck says lied change definitions
remove studies that prove their
statements false manipulation at the
highest level there is no amnesty for
those people yeah it's one of those
things it's like
you don't want to start you know coming
up with lists and hunting down people
and going after you know people that
weren't in major positions of power when
I say no amnesty I'm talking about the
people that were really in power I'm not
even necessarily talking about the the
TV host who lied or whatever like those
guys they should just not have jobs in
TV anymore something like that I'm
talking about the people that push this
nonsense the fact that fauci we've shown
you videos that he gets up there now and
says he had not he never called for
lockdowns and then it's like we show you
videos where he's like and we should be
locking down schools I never wanted to
close schools and then we show you
videos where he's literally saying it
it's like no you have to pay a price I
don't know what that price is are we
doing Nuremberg style trials are we
jailing people I don't know exactly what
that is but it's not good enough to just
be like oh we got on the other end of
kovid boy that was that was a scary
couple years and we did some crazy stuff
uh let's just keep going no there has to
be some comeuppance there has to be some
sort of Maya culpa because otherwise we
will be doomed to repeat it again
obviously obviously people have to
realize that there if you are going to
infringe on other people's rights there
has to be a cost right they wanted a
massive cost on us if we didn't want to
behave they want the way they wanted us
to behave well they have to realize
there's a cost if you come after our
constitutionally guaranteed rights Amy
Says quote public health is
misinformation there's only personal
health that's a great oh I like that
I like that that's a good one Amy we'll
credit you for that one that is a good
one you're right Public Health like
there's personal health take care of
yourself and if you take care of
yourself you might take care of the
people that are in your family that's
the personal situation around you and
then it extends to a community but
Public Health it's a very dangerous
thing and and that's why when they kept
saying well you have to do this to keep
Grandma safe and it's like all right but
why should a say 35 year old guy who eat
right eats right takes care of himself
is in no risk of covet have to do the
exact same thing and get injected in the
exact same way as say the 75 year old
chronic smoker who also has emphysema
and whatever else but we we did a lot of
bad stuff and we need an honest
assessment of it and I really think I
mean that's why I'm telling you that and
it's also why I think that that ad there
uh with DeSantis closing out this
campaign was so good it's like notice he
wasn't screaming about everything or
demonizing anyone or anything else what
do I keep saying we just have to get
back to a good America that we kind of
let go of the America of those kids in
that video I showed you yesterday of
shaving cream on Halloween
when New York City police officers in
1984 when they were mostly worried about
whether the kids were going to egg a car
or use shaving cream on it as opposed to
the mass violence that's happening now
when we really were post-racial it was
not cool to be racist as opposed to the
woke who've ushered in this idea that
we're all racist nobody cares about the
gender stuff and the sexuality stuff
like we're close to grabbing it back
it's not going to happen Nationwide and
they're not just going to let go right
like we're not just going to win this
election and a couple States will go red
and there'll be a better situation in
the Senate we'll get more of these
governorships it's not just going to
magically go away the machine just won't
let it go away but then at a more local
level you'll be able to incorporate a
little more freedom into your life how
cool would that be if you're watching
this and you live in Michigan right now
and you're just days away of from
getting rid of of Gretchen Whitmer you
know if you're in New York right now and
you're just days away of getting rid of
Lee zeldon Lee zeldon who by the way was
assaulted while giving a speech about
two months ago I don't remember Hillary
Clinton talking about that right
I think you guys got it I think you got
it uh as a reminder like And subscribe
on YouTube on Rumble and join us on
locals if you'd like to chat during the
show and I post some pictures the kids
and all sorts of stuff up there and we
leave you with more lies from the
elderly man pretending to be president
see you tomorrow and so folks I will
take care of this I will end this I will
make sure we have a plan I'm not going
to shut down the economy I'm going to
shut down the not going to shut down the
country I'm going to shut down the virus
I'm not going to shut down the economy
I'm not going to shut down the country
but I'm going to shut down the virus I'm
going to shut down the virus I'm going
to shut down the virus I'm going to shut
down the virus I'm going to shut down
the virus I'm going to shut down the
virus 220
000 Americans dead
you hear nothing else I say tonight
hear this look there is no federal
solution this gets solved at a state
level anyone is responsible for that
many deaths should not remain as
president of the United States of
America
foreign
you can be around the vaccinated or
unvaccinated people we're going to
protect vaccinated workers from
unvaccinated co-workers the choice is
yours
you all made this possible this is not
about Freedom or personal choice